when you talk about trump
or talk about biden i
think i'm trying to find a line to walk
where you they don't immediately put you
into the
this person has trauma derangement
syndrome or they have
the other the alternative to that i'm
more than happy
when people are preemptively dismissing
me because then i don't have to waste
time engaging with them
because those people be of no use to me
when i was on tim pool recently dimple's
show
uh tim pool is known for his little like
hat i got a propeller beanie motorized
and it was just spinning the whole
two hours i know the 1950s thing the
point being i wore
it because there's lots of people who
would say
i can't take seriously someone who wears
a hat like that and my point being if
you are the kind of person
who takes your cues based on someone's
wardrobe as opposed to the content of
your ideas
you're of no use to me as an ally so i'd
be more than happy you preemptively
abort rather than
waste our breath this is the deep this
is a very very deep thing that you and i
disagree on which is
this is goes to the trolling versus the
love uh
is i believe that person instinctually
dismisses you
on the very basic surface level yes but
deep down
there actually there's a wealth of a
human being
that seeks the connection to seeks to
understand
deeply to connect with other humans that
we should speak to
i think yes you and i completely
disagree see
you're saying i'm saying there's no mind
there literally
because okay so let's i naturally think
that the majority
so i naturally think the majority of
people are
have the capacity to be thoughtful
intelligent and um
you know learn about ideas ideas that
they
instinctually based on their own likes
current inner circle disagree with and
learn to understand
to empathize with the other like i and
in the current
climate there's a divisiveness that
discourages that and i
that's where i see the value of love of
of encouraging people to to uh
to strip away that surface instinctual
response based on the thing they've been
taught based on the things they listen
to to actually think deeply
have you ever had uh gone to cvs or
dwayne reed
and your bill how much you owe them is
six dollars
and you give them a ten dollar bill in a
single and watch the look on their face
you watch them void their bowels and
panic because you give them 11
on a six dollar bill this is not a mind
capable or interested in thoughts and
ideas of learning no you're talking
about the first moment
of uh for a first moment where there's
an opportunity to think
they are desperate to avoid it
no they're just it's and incapable of it
i i just
it's there they have the same exact
experiences i have every single day
when i know it's time for me to go on on
a run of five miles
or six miles or ten miles i'm desperate
to avoid it
and at the same time i know i have the
capacity to do it
and i'm deeply fulfilled when i do do it
when i do overcome that challenge
you are one of the great minds of our
generation you are telling me that any
of these people can do
anything close to the work you do not in
artificial intelligence but
in the in inability to be compassionate
towards other people's ideas like
understand them enough
to be able passion requires a certain
baseline of intelligence
because you have to perceive other
people as being different but of value
yeah exactly that's a sophisticated
mindset i think i think most people are
are capable of it you don't think so no
and nor are they interested in it
but in that kind of if you don't believe
they're capable of it how can anarchy
be stable uh if you have a farm
there's one farmer and 50 cows it's very
stable
you're just not you're not asking the
cows where to where to for
where to farm things yeah but
the cows aren't intelligent enough to do
damage
cows cows certainly bulls because they
could do a lot of damage they could
trample things they could attack you
cows are like how much did they weigh
like four thousand pounds can you
connect the analogy then because like
sure you can't expect yeah saying a cow
is a cow
isn't a slur it's not saying you hate
cows cows
or even let's say the example i always
use with good reason is dogs okay
uh i always say to study how human
beings operate watch caesar milan
because human beings and dogs have
co-evolved our minds have both evolved
in parallel tracks to communicate with
each other
dogs are can be vicious dogs for the
most part are great
wonderful but you can't expect the dog
to understand certain concepts it's not
an
ins and out most people are offended are
you saying like a dog if you're a dog
person like i
am this is actually a huge compliment
most dogs are better than most people
um but to get the idea that
this is something that is basically your
peer
is nonsensical now of course this sounds
arrogant and elitist and so on and so
forth
and i'm perfectly happy with that but it
is very hard
to persuade me or anyone that if you
walk george carlin has that joke think
how smart the average person is then
realize 50
of people are dumber than that if you
walk around and see who's out there
these people are very kind
they are of value they reserved to be
treated
with respect they deserve to be secure
in their person they deserve to feel
safe
and to have love but the expectation
that they should have any sort of
semblance of power over me in my life
is as nonsensical as asking lassie to be
my accountant
you